it's in the city that george floyd
called home for most of his life that
there is another fight for equality in
america
in houston in texas communities which
have faced
generations of voter discrimination say
it's happening again
what drove record turnout last year
things like drive-in voting
we saw again in local elections this
month but republicans
consumed by those unproven claims of a
stolen election
want new rules limiting things like
absentee voting
increasing election observers
campaigners say
making it harder for those who've been
disenfranchised before
since we were all in the car it was it
was an ability for them to kind of
experience voting with us all the way
through the norris family voted at a
drive-in
and see the worst of american history
now repeating
these are just the different versions of
what they were doing you know in the the
early
the early part of the 20th century the
you know the jim crow laws
that seems to be the general idea that
you can't win just suppress while we
have
the ability to suppress the vote every
time there is progress being made
we have obama in office then trump comes
right behind it i mean like every time
it feels like there's two steps forward
and five steps back
we aren't in chains and enslaved
but at the same time um if you were to
walk down the street with a weapon right
now because this is an open carry state
nobody's gonna say anything
to you if my husband does he'd be lucky
to get to the stop sign before the
neighbors come out and call the cops and
they come up here and they might shoot
him before he even gets down the street
we're still fighting you know it's a
daily fight
and it's not just here republicans in
georgia florida arizona pushing for more
restrictions
to change the voting landscape
the man who wrote the texas law says
it's about voter fraud
not voter suppression isn't this
republicans who've seen the white house
go they've seen the senate go
trying to make sure that doesn't happen
again i understand i've heard that
argument and
there's a big national debate going on
and i realize that's happening
here in texas this is not about the
outcome of the election
uh we like how things went in 2020
president trump won texas
i was related with 75 so i'm not
complaining about that
no matter who wins or who loses we want
the system to work right and so if it's
as secure and as accessible as we can
make it that's what we're going to do
but the politicians are now facing a new
obstacle from
corporate america high-profile companies
speaking out
these types of oppressive you know voter
restrictions are horrible for businesses
and show me a time in us history where
democracy has been increased whether
it's giving
women the right to vote are giving
people of color the right to vote
where that's led us to a bad place in
every case it's led to more prosperity
it's led to more business
it's led to a better society overall
[Applause]
it has added momentum to the protests
and that movement for a reckoning in
america
as this mural by the houston artist deck
reminds us george floyd's death shows
what's at stake
when the most basic rights are taken
away greg milam sky news texas